Big picture-- I showed you
this big picture before.
We're now going to add to it.
Look at what we've done.
Ha!
Electronic structure all the
way up through [INAUDIBLE],,
[? Louis, ?] molecular
orbital theory,
how to handle multi-electrons,
all these different kinds
of bonding--
check.
We've covered every
single one of these,
and this is
solid-state chemistry.
OK, but now here we are, right?
Now OK, remember we
also talked about this
on the very first lecture.
When you classify solids,
there are two things
that are really important.
One is the bonding type.
How do the atoms in the solid
want to talk to each other?
How do they interact?
And that is something that we
have covered in a lot of ways.
But the next is how
they come together,
the actual arrangement
of those atoms.
And that is what
we're going to talk
about today and on Wednesday.
And then after exam two as
we learn about X-rays, that's
a way to characterize
the arrangement
so that you can see how
they're ordered, OK?
We're going to use
X-rays and do something
called X-ray diffraction.
But for this week I want
to just classify it.
I want to talk about
the tools that we
use to understand
how a solid forms,
how to describe the
formation of a solid, how
the atoms can be described.
And OK, so, of
course, a solid is
that which is dimensionally
stable, simple definition,
right?
But we can break down
how these atoms arrange
into two basic categories--
atomic arrangement, the order,
and what we call it, right?
In the first category,
it's regular.
So what that means is
that everywhere I look, I
have the same thing repeating.
And you know what?
It repeats over a
long, long way--
like really long, OK?
So that kind of regular, long
range order is a crystal.
That's a crystalline solid.
And that is going to be
the topic of this week,
crystalline solids.
Now, there are also
solids that you can
make where there isn't order.
Or maybe there's
some but not much.
So, things are
kind of jumbled up.
They're not regularly repeating.
They might be random,
the atomic arrangement.
Or maybe there's repetition,
but it's very short-range.
So things look ordered, but only
for a few bond lengths, not 10
to the 23rd bond lengths, right?
Those are called amorphous
solids, or also glass.
Now, as I mentioned, this
is the topic of this week,
and this will be
covered on exam two.
This is the topic after
exam two next week, OK?
So we'll talk about both of
these types of solids as we go.
All right, now, OK, it
turns out that nature
has been thinking about
order for a long, long time.
And there is a reason for this.
Because nature wants
to be efficient.
This plant is like, well, I'm
only going to grow this big,
and I got to put as
many seeds as I can
on the surface of this thing.
How do I fit them--
how do I pack them in?
Well, I could fit
them randomly, but it
doesn't seem like I could
get as many seeds on there.
What if I packed them in
in some regular pattern?
What if I packed them
in in some regular way?
Well, you can pack
a lot more in.
And so nature has
already been thinking
about symmetry and order
and even long-range order
for a long time.
People have been
thinking about this, too.
Robert Hooke, the same person
from Hooke's law, in the 1600s
he was all about cannonballs.
And he was like, how
can I stack cannonballs?
And he tried this, right?
He's like, well, maybe if
I just put them like this,
is that a good
way to stack them?
I don't know.
And then he sort of
put them all together.
But now, he tried this, and then
he tried another arrangement,
and he'd be like,
well, but how--
first of all, are they stable?
Do they fall over easily?
Because you don't
want cannonballs
falling all over the place.
But then also, did
you pack as much
in this way as another way?
So he was thinking about it.
And he figured out that you
could pack more cannonballs
in the same area or volume if
you sort of switched it up,
right?
And then he thought, well, maybe
other things have packing, too.
And he thought about
all sorts of things.
He looked at salt
crystals, and he
said, they must also
pack in some way,
because cannonballs do.
So people have been thinking
about this for a long time, OK?
Now, people are also inspired
by regular order, right?
So if you look at, for
example, an Escher painting,
you can see that there is
a repetitive pattern here.
This is a crystal
of ducks, right?
OK, so now, when you look
at patterns like this,
you have to--
well, you don't have to, but
we have to in this class.
We've got to figure out
what is the repeating unit.
What is it that is
repeating everywhere?
So that's the first
question we need to ask.
And you can see if you
look at this picture,
you can draw a box like that.
There's a box around a light
colored, dark colored duck.
And now you see if you take
this box and you move it over,
you translate it over there,
you get exactly the same thing.
If you take that box
and you put it up there,
you get exactly the same thing.
So that is a repeating unit.
Oh, we have a definition.
It's a unit cell.
It's called a unit cell.
And it's the repeating
unit in a crystal.
It's a repeating unit.
Now, it's not always obvious.
So, there's one way that
I can repeat and take
this and make the picture
by repeating it everywhere.
But check this out--
I could have done that.
If you stare at that, you
can see that that is also
a repeating unit, right?
That is also repeating unit.
If I take this and
I move it down here,
I get exactly the same thing.
And I move it over there,
and I can tile all of space.
I can tile all of space.
And something is
really important here.
I can take these repeating
units and stamp them.
Oh, I like that word.
And I can tile all of space
and recreate this picture
without any voids, right?
I didn't miss anything.
I filled all of space.
And that is what a
crystal system is, right?
A crystal system--
let's write it here--
crystal system.
Crystal system-- that is
a way of enumerating--
enumerates ways that
space can be filled, OK?
Enumerates ways that space
can be filled with no voids.
That's a crystal system.
OK, well, let's go back to
the canons for a minute,
because we can think about
this first in 3D before we--
we're just warming up
before we get to 3D, OK?
Oh, there it is.
That's a unit cell.
OK, now the thing is, so
I've drawn a unit cell.
And notice what I've done.
I've taken this, and I've
drawn it this way, OK?
And those vectors define
the unit cell, right?
Those vectors define
the unit cell.
So those are my stamps,
the vectors there.
So these things here--
well, I went a little
far there, but they
should go to the center
of the next cannonball.
So now these are vectors.
If I just take these,
and I put them--
now, if I translate
them over to there,
then I get the next unit
cell and the next one.
And I go up, and I
go over, and I get
all the tiling of all space.
And so those vectors
are really important,
and they have a name.
Those are called
the lattice vectors.
Those are the lattice vectors.
I really like to think of them
as my stamps, or my stamp.
It is a stamp.
Mm!
And no voids-- these
reactors are my stamp.
Now, I'm stamping all of space.
I didn't really say
what I'm putting there.
I mean, here
there's cannonballs.
In Escher there's ducks.
Doesn't matter right now, right?
It's a stamp that
fills all of space.
That is how we're building
up our knowledge of crystals.
OK, well you can also
ask the question,
which is, how much
could you fill in there?
And that's a very important
question that we want--
ah-- --that we want to know.
OK, mm!
OK, now, so I've got
my lattice vectors.
But I want to know
now what am I--
because I could put there--
look at this.
I could take a lattice
vector like this.
This is a square lattice.
OK, if it's a square
lattice, then those
are the same length, right?
A is like the length of the--
this is like the length
of the lattice vector.
Now, if I took this lattice,
this stamp, and I say,
OK, now I'm going to
decide what to put there--
I'm going to put circles.
OK, so I'm going to put a
circle there, circle there.
And what you do then is
you put a circle everywhere
that you stamp, right?
OK, so I have now
taken my stamp,
and I've stamped everywhere.
And I've put something
at each place--
a circle.
But I might ask a question.
And this is a very
important question,
which is, if I have
circles, what is the maximum
that they can pack
in for this lattice?
How much can I pack?
Well, you can just
visualize that now.
Let's grow them.
A stamp means it's the same
thing everywhere, right?
So now if I make
one of them bigger,
well, I've made them
all bigger, right?
Because they're all
the same everywhere.
And if I make them
all big enough,
eventually they're going
to touch like that.
That's a special
thing, because now I've
grown the shape that I'm putting
there to the point where it's
the maximum packing, right?
And so you can imagine this.
The area of maximum packing
is a very important parameter.
And it's something that
we'll talk about today
with 3D crystals, which
is the solids of elements
in the periodic table.
But if you say with
this square analogy--
so my lattice is a square.
My stamp is a square.
My sides are equivalent.
And what I put
there is a circle.
Then the area of maximum
packing is something
you can calculate, right?
Because the circle itself--
in this case, if I--
[STUDENT SNEEZES]
Gezuntheit.
If I look at it, then--
oh, that's not a good circle.
But anyway, you'll get the
point here, which is that--
oh, boy-- which is that if
this is the lattice vector
is a, like I drew there and I'm
looking at the maximum packing,
then you know already that
the radius of the circle
is a half a.
So radius equals 1/2 a.
If the radius of the
circle is 1/2 a--
if the radius of
a circle is 1/2 a,
then you also know
what the area is.
I'm in 2D right now.
I'm in 2D.
So if I've maximized the
packing of these circles
on the square lattice,
then the area of the circle
is pi times r squared.
So 1/2 a squared equals
pi a-squared over 4.
But see, I also know how
much I packed it in, right?
And I'm doing this
slowly on purpose,
because we'll go faster when
we do some of the other ones.
But I want to do
the first one slow,
because then we'll all be
able to see what we're talking
about with the simplest case.
The area of the square
is a-squared, right?
And so the area of max packing
is equal to pi a squared over
a-squared--
pi over 4.
because the a-squared
is cancelled.
So it's 78%.
This is what Hooke was--
but did I max it out,
or could I do
something different?
Could I pick a
different lattice?
What if we made cannonballs
into rectangles?
Bad idea.
No, he stuck with spheres,
but how do you pack them in?
How can you arrange them in a
way to change the max packing?
That's what nature does
with atoms, as we'll see.
So for example, if I had a 2D
hexagonal lattice, instead of
my stamp being a square--
so if it were a 2D
hexagonal lattice--
I won't do this one out.
But then the max packing
goes all the way up to 91%.
That's a lot more per area--
max packing.
So this is something
that we care a lot about.
It's something that
we care about because,
when atoms see each
other in a solid, what's
the first thing they
want to determine?
The first thing they want to do
is they want to go back in here
and they want to be like,
which one of those can we do?
Can we find some way to bond?
That's what atoms do.
That's what everyone does.
How can we bond together?
What kind of relationship
are we going to have?
But they want to
max that out, right?
And so they want to try to pack
in, given the bond that they're
going to have.
And that is what's
going to dictate
the kind of arrangement they
can have in the crystal, OK?
So OK, so here we are.
And we're going from 2D to 3D.
Now, the thing is,
this is not going
to be an in-depth dive
into symmetry and space
groups and group theory.
Those are all great topics.
But I'm just going to tell you--
and it's actually kind of cool.
In 3D, there are only seven
unique crystal systems.
There are only seven ways
that you can do this.
You can only pack in
and have no voids--
and have no voids-- you can
only pack in these seven
different systems where, as you
can see, what's changing here?
Well, it's Cartesian
coordinates,
so you've got the length
of each lattice vector
and their relative
angles, right?
That's all you're changing.
Well, sometimes you change
all the angles at once, OK?
Sometimes you change only--
well, sometimes you
change only a few of them.
Sometimes you make
them all the same.
Sometimes you change a few.
Sometimes you have
all of them be even.
And sometimes some
of them are equal,
some of the lattice
lengths are equal
but another one is
different, all right?
These are the seven ways that
we can fill all of space.
And there are only seven.
In this class, we're only
going to focus on one,
and that's the cubic system.
And the reason is that
this gives us plenty
to work with to
understand crystallography
and how chemistry relates
to crystallography.
And there is the benefit of
the fact that a lot of elements
take one of these three--
actually, only two.
But they take cubic symmetry.
What does that mean?
Well, it means that all the
lattice vectors are the same.
Each one has a length a.
They're orthogonal to
each other, which means
that the angle is 90 degrees.
So we've got a cube.
Now, it turns out that now we
say, well, how do you pack?
How can I pack things
together in the cubic system?
And there's three
different ways to do it.
So what this is is it's more
symmetry and more group theory
and math that goes into this
that Bravais figured out.
And so we call these
Bravais lattices.
Now, what Bravais figured out--
and again, you don't need to
know all the math behind this,
but I want you to know
these three cubic lattices.
What you figured out is that
from the seven crystal systems,
there are only 14 ways to pack.
There are 14 ways to pack.
That's it, no more.
That's pretty cool.
There's no 15.
There's no 16.
There's 14 exactly--
14 ways that you can, by having
a lattice, which means a stamp,
there are only 14
ways you can do it
for the seven crystal systems.
And for the cubic system,
there's only three.
So I have three types of stamp.
That's what it means,
three types of stamps
where I leave no voids, right?
I leave no voids.
So I can tile all
of 3D space, right?
OK, and it forms a cubic
unit cell, cubic unit cell.
These are the three ways--
a simple cubic, a
body-centered cubic,
and a face-centered cubic.
These are the three
types of lattices
that have cubic symmetry.
They are the only three.
So in a Bravais
lattice, the difference
is in a Bravais lattice what
Bravais did was he enumerated--
so here we enumerate the
ways space can be filled.
He enumerated the
packing, all the ways
that the space can
be packed with,
for example, packing
within the unit cell.
So there's three distinct ways
to pack within a cubic unit
cell, OK?
That's what we're going
to bring to life today
and we'll talk more about
on Wednesday as well.
And what I want to do is I
want to go through each one.
So we're going to go
through simple cubic,
body-centered cubic,
face-centered cubic.
And then with each one,
I'm going to talk about it,
and then I'm going to
show you a little video so
that we can really see how the
unit cell gets kind of sliced
up.
And there's like a razor
that comes in and slices it.
It's really cool.
And so you can really see and
feel what we're talking about.
And speaking of seeing and
feeling, so I have these.
And I had wanted for these to
be what go in your goody bag.
But apparently like $100,000
is too much or whatever.
[LAUGHTER]
But so you have smaller
versions of these.
And I encourage you--
there's no better way to
think about crystallography
than to build stuff and see it.
You've got to do that.
It's really cool.
And so this is the simple cubic.
OK, so I'll pass that around.
And this is the
body-centered cubic.
And here you have
spheres, right?
That's fine.
But all we've done so
far is set up a lattice.
This could be anything.
It's a repeat lattice.
Well, that's what a lattice is.
The lattice just defines that
this is the same as this.
Whatever is here is the
same, is the same as this,
is the same as this.
That's what we're
defining here, OK?
OK, all right, now let's
talk about these three.
This is a picture
from [? April. ?]
These are the three systems
I just talked about,
the three Bravais lattices,
three different ways
to pack in a cubic
symmetric cell.
And notice there's three
ways of looking at it, right?
So here is sort of a
ball-and-stick model,
which makes it easy to see
the bonding and the atoms.
But the space-filling model
is really important here,
because the space-filling
model lets us think
about the maximum packing.
That's really important.
Remember the maximum
packing, because remember
these are bonding.
Really?
These are bonding
together, right?
So drawing them all the
way up to where they touch,
that's going to help
us understand what
their maximum packing can be.
So let's look at that
for the simple cubic, OK?
So for the simple cubic,
we'll do that here--
simple cubic.
OK, simple cubic-- oh, let's
just call it SC for short.
Why not?
Now, one of the things
you want to think about
is, how many nearest
neighbors do I have?
And I lost the--
so you can see.
Look at look at
the edge and think
about how many nearest
neighbors-- well, you
know you got six, right?
If you're in the corner there of
the cube in your simple cubic,
you've got six
nearest neighbors.
OK, that's important, right?
Six nearest neighbors--
why is it important?
Well, it's important
because that's
how many other atoms you could
bond with in this solid, OK?
But the other thing we want
to know is the packing.
Now, again, what you
want to do to figure out
the maximum packing is
you want to think about it
in the same way we did here.
Think about putting something
at each of the lattice points
and then growing
it out until they
can't grow any more, right?
And that's a good way
to think about it.
And in this case, we're
going to take spheres.
We're going to be taking
spheres because that's how
we're going to represent atoms.
So we're going to
be taking spheres.
And we're going to grow them
out and see what the packing is.
Yeah, but I've got to do
the same trick I did here.
I've got to do the
same trick I did here.
I've got to write the radius of
the atom in terms of the unit
cell.
So if the unit cell--
oh, boy.
I'm going to be
drawing a 3D structure.
Danger!
a, a, a-- that's a cube.
All the sides are a.
I made myself very happy.
It's a cube.
Now-- oh, but we have a cube.
Now, OK, here we go.
This one-- oh, but see,
I want maximum packing.
So I'm going to grow them out.
And you can see what's going
to happen as I do that.
And so you can see that in the
case of a simple cubic lattice,
it's just like in
the square lattice.
It's just like in the
square lattice, right?
When I've grown out the sphere,
the radius of that sphere,
the radius is r equals--
now, oh, wait a second.
OK, so I have 4/3 pi r--
OK, but that doesn't matter yet.
Don't do volume.
Think about the radius
OK, the radius is just going
to be 1/2 the lattice, right?
So radius is 1/2 a.
Volume is 4/3 pi 1/2 a cubed.
Now, this is important.
That is at the max packing.
OK, so I've grown
these volumes out,
and I've seen what
the packing can be.
Now, we actually call this--
so now I've got the
volume of an atom.
I'm pretending that
these are atoms now.
No, I'm not pretending anymore.
It's real.
These spheres are now atoms.
And OK, so that's the
volume of the atom, right?
And so we can write
atomic packing fraction
as the volume of the atom
over the volume of the cell.
That's exactly what
I did up here, right?
That's how we got the
area of the square,
the area of the circle, right?
But there's one more thing
that's really important,
which is it has to be times the
number of atoms in the cell.
When I say cell,
I mean unit cell.
It has to be times the number
of atoms in the unit cell.
So it's however
many atoms I have
times the volume of the atom.
OK, that's good.
That's how much is
inside of the cell
divided by the
volume of the cell,
and that gives me the
atomic packing fraction.
So in the case of
a simple cubic,
the APF, the Atomic
Packing Fraction,
is equal to pi over
6, which is 52%.
That's not very good, all right?
That's not-- well, I
mean, it's relative.
We don't know yet.
But it feels kind of low--
52%.
So with a simple
cubic lattice, all
I can do in my wildest dreams
is cover 52% of that volume.
That's not very-- that
doesn't feel like a lot.
And in fact, when you look
at the periodic table, what
you find is that there's
only one element--
one-- that takes the
simple cubic lattice.
Anybody know what it is?
Of course-- it's polonium.
[LAUGHTER]
Of course.
That's a really good
conversation starter.
I'm just saying.
That is a great
way to meet people.
Which one?
It's polonium?
Why?
Relativity.
In polonium, those electrons
are so high energy--
literally.
They're so high energy
they're like close
to the speed of light.
They're relativistic.
Their mass is heavier.
All sorts of interesting
things happen.
Polonium is the only one
that goes simple cubic.
I promised a video.
Oh, there's the-- oh.
Ha.
a-- a-- a.
There is a diagonal.
There is another diagonal.
Oh!
We're going to
come back to this.
Let's draw that.
Because that might
be important, right?
So if I have a cube,
then this diagonal,
if that's a and that's
a, then that is a root 2.
And the body diagonal--
that's the body diagonal--
is a root 3--
equals a root 3, right?
OK, we'll come back--
oh, I didn't need that,
because this is just a over 2.
But whoa, hold on.
We're coming to it.
But I promised a video first.
So here's a video with
the laser coming in.
And you're going to
really see-- this
will come to life a little bit.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [INAUDIBLE] of a cube.
The simple, or primitive
cubic unit cell
has particles at
the corners only.
In reality, the
particles lie as close
to each other as possible.
Note that the particles
touch along the cube edges
but not along a diagonal in
the face or along a diagonal
through the body.
By slicing away parts that
belong to neighboring unit
cells, we see that the
actual unit cell consists
of portions of the particles.
When the cells pack next to each
other in all three dimensions,
we obtain the crystal.
If we fade the others out,
you can see the original group
of eight particles within
the array and the unit cell
within that group.
We find the number of particles
in one unit cell by combining
all the particles' portions.
In the simple cubic unit cell,
eight corners, each of which
is 1/8 of a particle,
combine to give one particle.
A key feature of a
crystal structure
is its coordination number, the
number of the nearest neighbors
surrounding each particle.
In a simple cubic array,
any given particle
has a neighboring particle
above, below, to the right,
to the left, in front,
and in back of it,
for a total of six
nearest neighbors.
The body-centered
cubic unit cell has a--
[END PLAYBACK]
OK, so you see-- that
was so cool, right?
Like unh, unh, and you're
figuring out how many
atoms are in the cell, right?
Well, why didn't you just
put the atom in the middle?
You could do that, but then
it's not at the point, right?
So you've got to understand,
the concept of the lattice
is that whatever I put here,
wherever my vectors go,
that's what I put there
and there and there.
And so we often as a
standard, we say, well, OK,
what did I put there?
I put an atom and then
I put another atom.
But then your unit
cell is that cube.
And so we cut the unit
cell, and you're like, well,
how many atoms do I have in it?
Well, let's see.
I got one here, but it's shared
with all these other cubes,
so there's an 1/8 of an atom
there and 1/8 of an atom there.
We add them all up, and you
get one atom right back,
which you knew--
which you knew.
And by the way, this
was not 1 over a.
It was.
I wrote it mistakenly 1 over a.
The radius is 1/2 a over
there, which is correct here.
OK, good.
Now, next crystal
structure-- oh, look.
How do you know what
crystal structure--
there it is right there!
It's the periodic table!
To the rescue again--
he had it right there.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
That means T-shirts and T-shirts
and T-shirts and T-shirts.
[CHATTER]
All right, I'm going all the
way up there and up there.
We'll bring more.
You bring a periodic
table like that--
what is a crystal symmetry?
I know.
Which one is simple cubic?
Polonium.
Where's-- it's only polonium.
Oh, there it is--
polonium.
Thank you for being
representative
of simple cubic crystals.
But now we're talking
about the next kind,
which is body-centered cubic.
And look, a lot more have
a body-centered cubic.
And here, OK, so if it's
BCC, Body-Centered Cubic,
well, now you know if I take
these atoms at these corners,
and I add now--
there's a lattice
that takes me to the middle.
Remember, my lattice is
giving me this symmetry.
My lattice is giving me this.
So it means whatever I put
here, I put in all the corners
and I put in the middle, right?
That's BCC.
That's what BCC means.
Well, and yeah,
if you grow that--
OK, so first of all,
eight nearest neighbors--
eight nearest
neighbors-- well, you
can see that, because
I've got the six,
but then I've got
these ones here, right?
I've got actually
it's not the six.
I've got the one
along the diagonal,
which is kind of the point
I wanted to make next.
Oh, this is BCC.
This is BCC, right?
Now, how do you
see that it's BCC?
Because you stare at it and you
stare at it and you build it.
You get together with friends.
You get together with friends,
and you build even more.
And you see how much you can
build, and then you look,
and you see, look here it is.
There is my square, right?
OK, and there's another square.
And that's my cube.
And you go like this.
And then you're like,
oh, look, and there's
an atom in the middle.
That's BCC.
And they're all the same.
That's BCC, right?
But see, because this is
defined by the lattice,
I could have made
my square anywhere.
This didn't have to
be the middle atom.
I could move it
over, and then this
would be the middle
atom or this, right?
They're all equivalent.
It's a lattice.
Now, if you look at this and you
take that square or that cube,
then what you'll find
is that if you go along
the body diagonal-- see, now
I'm going to take each of these,
and I'm going to grow them.
Where do the atoms touch?
If I grow the atoms
in a BCC crystal,
they touch along the
body diagonal first.
Now, that's really important.
Let's pass this one around, too.
That's really important, OK?
Because now we have this concept
that is also very important,
which is the
close-packed direction--
close-packed direction.
And for the BCC structure,
it's the body diagonal.
Over here it's the cube edge.
For a simple cubic,
it's the cube edge.
Cube edge is the close-packed--
OK, how is that going to work?
I'll do this.
No, that's going
to be confusing.
Cube edge close-packed--
oh, that's really small.
But you get my point,
close-packed direction.
Close-packed direction,
body diagonal--
what that means is that--
and you can see it right here.
If you go all the way back
to this-- there it is.
As I grow these--
these are the same.
They're colored blue just for
clarity, just you can see.
But these are the same
because it's a BCC lattice.
And as I grow them, these
all have the same radius.
These are the ones that touch
first along the diagonal, not
those, all right?
Not those.
And that feeds into what
the radius is of the atom.
I do the same trick, and the
APF is going to be 4/3 pi.
And now I've got
my a root 3 over 4.
Why?
Because a is the
length of the cube.
And you can see here I've
got four radii, right?
Two diameters of the sphere
go down the body diagonal.
So r cubed, 4/3 pi
r cubed, is going
to be the volume of a
maximally-packed sphere
in a BCC lattice.
So this has to be divided by the
whole volume, which is a-cubed.
But I'm missing something,
because there's not just one.
There's not just one.
There's another one.
There's actually two
atoms in a unit cell.
There's two of these.
You can see that
one in the middle
and then that eighth,
eighth, eighth, eighth.
You've got two.
So I've got to multiply it
by 2, and it gives you 68%,
is the APF.
And that's why so many more
structures, especially metals,
are happy to be BCC.
Let's watch the video
again, or a different video,
this one on BBC.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --particle at each corner
and one in the center,
which is colored pink to
make it easier to see.
With full-size
spheres, you can see
that the particles don't touch
along the edges of the cube.
Close-packing
- But each corner particle does
touch the one in the center.
The actual unit cell
consists of portions
of the corner particles and
the whole one in the center.
Eight eighths give one particle.
And the one in the
center gives another,
for a total of two particles.
In this tiny portion of a
body-centered cubic array,
you can see that any
given particle has
four nearest neighbors
above and four
below, for a total of
eight nearest neighbors.
[END PLAYBACK]
OK, now it's really
important, right?
Just so you see conceptually,
visually how we got this,
the close-packed direction for
BCC is four times the radius.
I want to write that,
four times the radius.
And it's that thing
that we're doing now
a couple of times, where you've
got the radius of this sphere
that you're packing in
with a given symmetry.
But I've got to
write that in terms
of the lattice vectors, which
are in this case all a, right?
So it's really easy.
But they're all a, so I've
got to write it in terms
of the length of the lattice.
That's how you get the
atomic packing, OK?
Good, now the last one is FCC.
Look at how many elements
take the FCC form.
How do you know?
You bring out the periodic
table, and you look it up.
Now, many of these elements
can take different crystal
symmetries.
The ones that are listed are
the ones that are often--
well, always the most
stable one, right.
They're the most stable one.
But sometimes they can take
many different symmetries
if you do something like
add temperature or pressure
or other things to the system.
What's in the periodic table
is the most stable one.
Now, the FCC is the last one
that we're going to care about.
And it is the
face-centered cubic.
Now, OK, so on this one,
this is the face, right?
So we've got these atoms that
are sharing across the face.
And then we've got these
atoms here at the corners.
There's nothing in the middle
now, but they're on the faces--
sorry, the corners and
the faces, all right?
And so if you look
at this, what you
can see from looking at this--
and you've got to look at it.
Where's my cube?
Where's my unit cell?
You now know it's called
the unit cell, right?
Oh, and I see.
And then there's the
face atom, right?
There's a square there.
Then there's the
atom in the face.
And then there's
nothing in the middle.
It's not BCC, right?
But if I look at
another edge of that,
there's the atom in that face
and so on and so on, right?
Now, what's really
cool about FCC
is that it's got a
lot of neighbors.
And it's got more packing.
So for FCC, this is the
close-packed direction.
Close-packed
direction is the face,
is the-- did I write down?
I didn't write down.
OK, that's fine.
It's the face diagonal,
which is a root 2 in length.
And so the nearest
neighbors is 12.
And the atomic packing fraction
for FCC is 4/3 pi times--
and now here we go, right?
When I expand them,
it's along the face
that they're going
to touch, right?
So that's the
close-packed direction.
Face diagonal, that's
this one here, right?
So it's a root 2 over 4, right?
Because again, I've got
a radius and another
and another and another.
There's two diameters worth
that go across that face.
And so that's going to be
cubed, OK, divided by a-cubed.
Now, is there something missing?
Yes.
The number of atoms.
If you look at a FCC crystal,
and you look at the corners,
each one of those shares
with eight other unit cells,
so there's 1/8.
That gives you the one,
like in our simple cubic.
But now you've got all these
ones sharing across faces.
You've got six of those,
each one sharing 1/2 atom.
So that's three more.
So there's 4.
And this gives you a very
nice packing of 74%--
74%.
Let's see what our video
guy says about FCC.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- The face-centered cubic unit
cell has a particle at each
corner and in each face,
which are colored yellow here,
but none in the center.
The corner particles
don't touch each other.
But each corner does touch
a particle in the face.
And those in the faces
touch each other as well.
The actual unit cell
consists of portions
of particles at the
corners and in the faces.
Eight-eighths at the
corners gives one particle.
And half a particle
in each of six faces
gives three more, for a
total of four particles.
In this tiny portion of a
face-centered cubic array,
notice that a given particle
has four nearest neighbors
around it, four more
above, and four more below,
for a total of 12
nearest neighbors.
Stacking spheres shows how the
three cubic unit cells arise.
Now we talk about packing.
- Arranged a layer of spheres
in horizontal and vertical rows.
Note the large, diamond-shaped
space among the particles.
Placing the next layer
directly over the first
gives a structure based on
the simple cubic unit cell.
Those larger spaces mean an
inefficient use of space.
In fact, only 52% of
the available volume
is actually occupied by spheres.
Because of this inefficiency,
the simple cubic unit cell
is seen rarely in nature.
Polonium!
- A more efficient
stacking occurs
if we place the second
layer over the spaces formed
by the first layer
and the third layer
over the spaces
formed by the second.
That simple change leads to
68% of the available volume
occupied by the
spheres and a structure
based on the body-centered
cubic unit cell.
Many metals, including
all the alkali metals,
adopt this arrangement.
For the most
efficient stacking--
Now watch this.
- --shift every other row in
the first layer so the large,
diamond-shaped spaces become
smaller triangular spaces,
and place the second
layer over them.
Then the third layer
goes over the holes
visible through the
first and second layers.
In this arrangement, called
cubic closest packing,
spheres occupy
74% of the volume.
Note that it is based--
[END PLAYBACK]
--on the FCC crystal,
Bravais lattice.
That's what he
meant to say there.
And you really see it
come to life, right?
I wish I could do this
somehow with the 3D models.
But you stare at the 3D models
and you see that-- you know,
what's interesting is
the way you put it--
you slide-- this is what Hooke
did with the cannonballs.
You slide that base
layer, and then you
can stack them differently.
But it's still a cubic
system, FCC, all right?
We'll pick up on
this on Wednesday.